our next guest is an amazing hilarious
actor and stand-up comedian and you know
him as elliot goss in the hit show
search party take a look
so what did you have in mind well i
think it's safe to say we would prefer a
boy
a gay baby boy or even queer a queer
baby
and of course we are very open to all
ethnicities and religions but it would
be ideal if they were 511 at the
shortest so that they could carry us up
the stairs to bed when we're very
elderly and one blue eye and one brown
eye baby like husky but it would also be
good if he can make us feel protected
like a dad like a son that feels like a
dad
[Applause]
i'm so excited to speak with you you
have
so many layers to you
one thing that i really appreciated that
you talked about was like early in
comedy
how you were trying to find yourself how
did you
come around and find your style
well i think i was like really um i was
really scared of being confessional or
something at first like i felt like that
was like too normally and so it was like
the first couple years of doing stand up
i was like really like weird
and like i would like get up on stage
and like jump into a character with like
no introduction and and then i was like
this is so like hostile and alienating
like what are you doing and then
eventually you know and then i and then
i i started being a little more like
straightforward and direct did you find
that eventually
when it's personal is when it works the
best
you know i would say there are no hard
and fast rules but for me that was true
that's my truth yeah i feel like i even
posed that question rhetorically which
isn't fair like yeah it felt unfair
but it's like no matter what we do as
long as it's
some form of our truth our heart our
life experience then it can be spun into
anything yeah but it's got some core of
personal yeah i think that's true okay
so now that you've tackled
who you are on stand-up stages yes who
you are in childhood in adulthood search
party comes along yeah and it becomes
this absolute phenomenon i i hope that's
true sometimes it feels like no one's
watching it i can tell you this is what
everybody loves and it's a show that's
evolved and grown
i mean people really love it the people
who love it
that's sweet i know you're lying
i know you're lying
um no they
the people who love it love it it has a
real cult following and that is like
sometimes when i feel like no one's
watching it i'm also like but everything
i've ever loved took like 10 years for
people to appreciate you know so that's
that's what i you know think about as i
go to sleep tonight i think you know
it's appreciated with the fact that it
also like now in the business a great
marker of success is where
a big place will come and pick up your
show from another place and give me a
second life yeah it's really true no one
was really watching us and then we moved
to hbo max and had a it was on tbs and
now it's like coming to a close when
it's like the most talked about the most
successful the most prominent your swan
songing how does that feel
um it's you know i don't know it's it's
a very like the show itself is very kind
of unsentimental which is what i love
about it it has like it's really like
rude it has like teeth you know i love
when you say that it has teeth i mean
you don't just talk to melanie that's
fangs and yellow jackets has teeth
absolutely that's what people i think
that's what people want and i feel like
people are ready for teeth again they're
ready it just cycles
yeah yeah it's like
you read the room
or maybe you try to be greedy and fit it
all into one thing or maybe you
fluctuate from teeth to sweet but we
vacillate as human beings we are not one
thing yes and people love search party
for that very reason totally it also
changed and grew and was bold and tried
all these things that you know that is a
testament i think for other shows to
follow
yeah to say
don't stay in a flight pattern
totally i mean it has this like real
like it does have like a really crazy
scope it goes to wild places and then
what i do appreciate about it though is
that the characters kind of always kind
of stay the same like in a classic tv
comedy way okay the first episode like
gave me like these weird feelings
because i grew up in los angeles in
those exact neighborhoods with those
exact hipsters yeah yeah i have been at
those parties like everyone in the show
brunches yeah by the way it's like
portlandia brunch is like the saturday
night club
of the now you know we used to go to
discotheques and now we go to brunch but
i want to go back i want to go back to
disco me too
dancing i wanna dance is important it
really is no you are a big tony collette
fan you like have a present fan club
like a whole thing with her well i'm
sure she's so sick of me talking about
this on tv she's probably so scared of
me at this point but yeah when i was
when i was like 10 11 i i saw the movie
clockwatchers and then i saw muriel's
wedding and i was like oh my i was
i was just in the way that you can be as
an adolescent just like so full body
obsessed you know
and i started a website for her
it was like a full-time job i gotta tell
you yeah i know tony yeah she is
hilarious i bet you she loves this who
wouldn't love it
she's been very gracious with me when
the times where i've like forced her to
you know
talk about it and um but i'm she's she's
been very very sweet she's a spitfire
she's so cool and she is one of the
greatest actresses to have ever lived
period yeah
muriel's wedding from muriel's wedding
to the sixth
to in her shoes is one of my oh my god
performances now knives out the woman
can do no wrong and she is a hoot and a
blast and in fact i heard you have a
birthday coming up oh i do
interesting well we wanted to get you
something for you really
yeah we do
and we have it here right now what is it
oh my god wow
[Applause]
um it's a tony collette birthday cake
do i just stick my hand in what do i do
i mean
i would motorboat
go right in there out of respect to tony
i won't motorboat it but this is so
beautiful i thank you so much
how does tony tate oh she tastes
incredible
well i have to tell you tony i love you
so much
and you are worthy
of
fandom fan club yes love letters all of
it i think you picked so well thank you
so much i had taste i really had to
really do not many 10 year olds were
doing tonic websites um
i hear you're meeting with a mitzi
bananamore later
it's so crazy because you know i'm a
comedian and like she was obviously such
a huge influence for me coming up in the
scene
and like i just
i'm just so honored i can't wait to meet
her
[Music]